hello everyone and welcome to another
game uh from the quarterfinals of the
fiji world cup 2021 it's magnus carlsen
versus etienne bakro
uh and if you remember in their first
game uh magnus won with the black pieces
so now etienne must do the same in order
to force tie breaks and it's not
easy uh the only one who was able to get
a win so far in defeating world cup is
yesipenko but
that was in the rapid time format where
you know things get really really crazy
and uh you know
anything can happen but forcing a win
with the black pieces in classical chess
that is much much different so let's see
how etienne did here
and what he chose as his weapon so
without further ado let's check it out
magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with e4
and of course what do you do when you go
for a win uh you play the sicilian we
have c5 uh we have knight to f3
d6 and now magnus doesn't want to go d4
and then allow black to go maybe for
some crazy night or
uh he plays bishop to b5 with check
going for the canal attack
we have bishop the d7 and magnus trades
off a pair of light square bishops so
captures captures and
now c for grabbing more space here uh in
the center controlling the d5 square
we have e5 by black and not knights the
c3 so this is a
characteristic of this opening that
white will have an excellent outpost on
d5 and black can do absolutely nothing
about that and black will have an
excellent outpost on d4
uh similar to white's outpost on d5
so it's a really uh interesting position
uh you could also uh you know
place some knights here on f5 and f4 but
uh
you know it's uh it's a very
characteristic
position uh for this opening so here we
have knight to c6
and now d3 and here the usual way
uh black will continue is g6 this is by
far the most popular move
uh knight to gta 7 also played there are
a couple of other moves
they're not played as much but the move
atm played
was never played before he plays f5 and
it is now already as of move seven that
we have a completely new game
and as you can see atien is really going
for it he wants to win the game with
the black pieces against magnus carlsen
in classical time format
so here magnus captures on e5 with e
captures queen captures a very active
square for the black queen
and now while we could go for something
like knight to d5
threaten knight c7 black will very
happily castle here
and it's probably the uh the position
atn wanted
so here magnus just plays knight to g5
kind of
uh improving the position of the knight
the knight is coming to e4 so you don't
really gain anything by challenging it
and you're still waiting to see how
black will develop his pieces and where
the king will go
so here we have bishop to e7 now with an
attack on the knight
knight to g to e4 and here knight to f6
and now
magnus feels comfortable about castling
kingside and he goes for it castles
kingside
and uh etienne also castles kingside
here castling queenside would be
uh really really crazy but it would
probably favor white white is probably
much faster here since uh he can just
play maybe a3 b4 must open the position
and it's going to be very hard for
for black to play this um successfully
so instead after knight to f6 we have
king side castles uh by
both of them so castles castles and now
f4 by magnus he wants to open up df file
for his rook as
black also has a semi-open uh f file uh
we have e
captures uh not queen captures obviously
e captures on f5
bishop captures on f5 and now knight
captures on e4
you don't have any discoveries with the
bishop because black would very happily
play
queen captures on f1 so d captures an e4
attacking the queen
queen to g6 and now knight to d5
and excellent square for this knight
attacking the bishop here
and you don't wanna you know blunder
something like if you play knight to d4
you we can capture this and you blunder
a queen
uh not likely for uh you know players of
d strength but
you you have to be careful about uh you
know stuff like that
so bishop the g5 offering to trade off
the the
dark square bishops as well and magnus
simply develops the queen and connects
the rook so queen to d3 also adds a
defender to the e4 pawn
uh we have knights the d for black also
now with the excellent outpost for his
knight and the bishop to g3 now
preparing to trade off rooks along the f
file so rook captures on f1
rook captures and now rook to e8 you
could also
play rook to f8 but at the end needs to
avoid any
unnecessary uh trade-offs uh because uh
well he needs to create a winning chance
so he developed the rook to e8
goes after the e4 pawn uh we have rook
to e1 defending
and now uh the position is completely
equal
both players have identical pieces
identical number of pawns so everything
is
you know uh working well for both of
them uh the problem is uh magnus is
satisfied with a draw here as
he he goes into the semi-finals of the
filia world cup if he gets a draw in
this game
and at the end needs a winter you know
four star break so here we have h5
trying to you know uh stir some trouble
we have h3 freeing up this h2 square for
for his bishop and now king the h7 we
have bishop to f2 now preparing to
pick up the knight and the win the pawn
here so knight back to c6
and b3 now uh atm shifts the knight over
to e5
and queen to e2 we have bishop to h6 now
putting pressure along the g
file so if uh you know you're not
careful a move like knight to f3 could
really hurt uh if for example the queen
moves somewhere
so king not queen to f1 king the h2
and now the king is no longer on the
same uh foul as the queen
and knight the c6 now now the knight can
again uh come to
uh d4 and attack the white queen queen
to f3
and now knight back to e5 and magnus
simply repeats queen to e2 he says i'm
very happy with the draw here
but at the end obviously it isn't so he
has to continue we have rook to f8
and now bishop to g3 uh we have knight
back to c6 and now
rook to f1 magnus offers a a trade of
rooks
we have rook back to e8 and now rook to
e1
again magnus is very happy with the draw
here he he has nothing to
to prove uh we have knights the d4
attacking carlson's queen
queen to f2 and now b6 and now what do
you play here
uh well magnus plays h4 and he says
there's no way
you can do anything here this position
is impenetrable uh and
uh you know i'm i'm off to the
semi-final so you know sorry about that
uh but etienne uh decided to try he said
all right
the e4 pawn is attacked twice i know
capturing it is
isn't a great move but i'm gonna try i
have to create some sort of an imbalance
in the position
uh and hope for the best so he played
rook captures on e4
uh and magnus now of course plays knight
to e7
attacking the black queen here uh and uh
well if
you attack if you capture which is what
happened in the game then
uh magnus simply wins the exchange so
here uh you
you should play some like queen to e6 or
even queen to g for this is a
best for black but it doesn't really
matter because it's it's such a forcing
line rook captures queen captures and
queen to f7
threatening checkmate and now black
doesn't want to get checkmated he has to
play knight
to f3 check and that's it if queen
captures we capture the knight here and
if g
captures we get a nice draw by perpetual
checking king h3 queen f1 check you go
here i go here you go here i go here and
it's going to be a draw by perpetual
if black wants to survive so at the end
of course
has to avoid this again he has to not go
for the best move because
he knows this is the best move but the
the best move is not enough here
so rook captures on e7 he gives up the
exchange
rook captures and not knights to f5
attacking the
uh the rook here we have rook back to e2
the rook will help out nicely here with
the defense of the
uh willow of everything basically and
now knight the d4
again uh improving the position of the
knight attacking the rook rook back to
e1
and now queen to d3 so hoping for
something
uh but there is uh well not not a lot to
hope for magnus played bishop to f4
uh and now knight back to f5 we have
bishop captures on h6
knight captures on h6 and now queen to
f3 magnus offers a queen trade
and of course uh the the end game is
lost for black if the queens get traded
off so here
knight the g4 check was played by atn uh
magnus played king to g3
and he was in this position that uh at
the end vacro resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
the problem is uh
well white will simply uh tr trade
queens not trade queens white is
threatening to pick up the black queen
so if you
if trade uh the end game is lost it's uh
incredibly easy for
uh for white to you know just go to the
seventh rank uh
uh you know upgrade the rook to a pig
and pick up those pawns
and you can't really avoid a queen trade
if you play queen queen to g6 queen to
c2 queen anywhere
for example along this diagonal we're
just going to deliver a check here force
a queen trade
and it's pretty much the same black has
nothing to hope for if you block the
uh the rook's uh attempt to go to the
seventh rank with 95 we're going to play
this again hope the
you know undermine those pawns from
behind king g8 now we simply go
after this pawn and it's it's too easy
to uh
to attack the position if g6 we go rook
to f6 now we go after this pawn
and you you can't simply defend all of
them
you will slowly but surely you know
worse in your position and it's
going to be a winning game for white as
it already is
so uh basically uh nothing bad happened
for black here at the end
i just got a uh you know a draw against
magnus uh because uh
there was there were no chances in this
game magnus just took it to a nice calm
game and you know
it's not not a problem for him in a
classical game with the white pieces and
in order to
uh create some winning chances etienne
first uh had to pick up that pawn
and then he decided to give up the
exchange and then little by little
to avoid a draw he had to lose the game
in order
to get a winning chances just is weird
like that
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna check out at
least one more game because
there were uh well all of the games from
the semifinals were decisive from round
two so that we're going to check out at
least one more game
uh i would like to thank yaroslav
lubelski matthew
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the feeder
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day